join me now Shadow climate change in Net
Zero secretary Ed miliban very good
morning uh good afternoon excuse me uh
thanks so much for for joining us I
actually wanted to start if I may on the
the policies overall designed to boost
labor participation and uh Rachel Reeves
is on with us this morning said that
labor would look to reverse the changes
in pension policy what what would labor
do instead to try and boost labor
participation rates well look the big
picture on this and I'll come to your
question in a second is that the ifs as
we heard earlier are saying this is the
worst decade for living standards
frankly in history uh the worst fall in
living standards since records began I
think it's such a contrast 24 hours on
from the budget between what the experts
are now saying and the sort of tone of
Jeremy Hunt which was deeply complacent
about what so many families in our
country are going through and that takes
me to your point about pensions tax
relief against that backdrop of a cost
of living crisis like we haven't seen
for 70 years in this country the idea
that the priority for this budget was to
give a billion pounds to the top one
percent of people in our country strikes
us as the wrong priority labor wouldn't
have done it we would reverse it as for
increasing labor Supply there's all
kinds of things that we can do our
shadow work and pension secretary
Jonathan Ashworth has come forward with
proposals on helping the other 50s back
to work we support measures on child
care but you know there's even doubt
about whether this will have much of an
impact on labor Supply this pensions tax
relief change and it certainly isn't
fair
uh we've only got a couple minutes
because I know we've got to break uh the
ECB decision so a broad question about
tax policy clearly corporate tax rates
are going up but with various exemptions
being thrown in what would you like to
see there does that make sense to you to
Target where the exemptions would be
felt or or would labor just uh uh cut
corporate taxes well I'll tell you one
exemption we wouldn't be having and that
is a massive tax relief for the fossil
fuel industry for oil and gas producers
you see what happened in the budget and
again this is a sign of the wrong
priorities is that yes a windfall tax
has been introduced on those big oil and
gas companies making record profits and
we called for that for over a year but
the government has introduced a massive
loophole to the student of billions of
pounds now we say the right priority for
the country is to use those billions of
pounds to help tackle the cost of living
crisis and as for growing the economy
which is a massive absence frankly from
this budget we would have a proper green
Prosperity plan to invest in those new
industries of the future like hydrogen
like Renewables like electric vehicle
production because this is the big
growth opportunity of the 21st century
and as businesses saying the government
is missing the boat on it
and and just uh finally Mr miliban do
you welcome the growing commitment from
the government towards nuclear power
I support nuclear power yes what I what
I find when I listen to the government
is that they are very good at
proclaiming their commitment and very
bad at building nuclear power stations
you know when we left office in 2009 I
had identified well in 2010 but in 2009
I identified 10 potential sites for
nuclear power stations one of them is
going to have the Hinckley Point Power
Station built on it uh towards the end
of this decade so you know the
government likes to talk a lot about
nuclear power it doesn't deliver and
frankly they've got to deliver across
the board we should get rid of the
onshore wind ban we should speed up and
Turbo Charge solar power why it's the
right thing for climate but crucially
it's the right thing to cut bills too
because we now know that Renewables are
the cheapest alternative we have in this
country and uh I've got time for one
more finally finally the the booster
child care is that something that that
labor welcomes overall yes we do welcome
it in fact we've been calling for it we
would like to see it come in as soon as
possible we've shown for example that by
getting rid of the tax relief for
non-doms people who live in Britain but
don't pay taxes in Britain we could
actually fund breakfast clubs which are
a crucial part of the child care package
we'd like to see all of that brought in
as quickly as possible we think
certainly the breakfast clubs in every
Primary School could come in uh much
earlier but but yes we need to move
forward on this and as fast as possible
and miniband thank you very much for
joining us uh today much appreciated